if you've watched my review of Disney's
new live-action beauty in the beach
movie you'll know how much I enjoyed it
but now I want to see how much the
superfan you are of the original
animated movie which by the way was the
first animated feature ever to be
nominated for a Best Picture Oscar
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to be
revealing a wealth of fascinating facts
about Disney's classic animation Beauty
and the Beast
so be my guest and put your Disney
knowledge to the test when it came to
creating a book loving Belle the
filmmakers took their cues from the
Golden Age of Hollywood
for example Belle's blue and white
outfit channels actress Judy Garland's
look in The Wizard of Oz as well as
emphasizing visually just how different
Bella's from the people in her town is
she's the only character who was blue in
the opening sequence Bert's Belle's
costume isn't the only thing that links
her to Judy Garland in fact one of the
reasons that page O'Hara was selected to
bring Belle to life was that her voice
and manner were reminiscent to the
quality and warmth of Garland's voice
other Hollywood icons also left their
mark on the character of bow for example
screenwriter Linda Woolverton took cues
from actress Katharine Hepburn's
especially her performance as a spirited
and literature loving Jo March in the
1930s film Little Women
and that was just the beginning of
screen legend Hepburn's influence on the
animated classic indeed Belle's
interaction with the Beast for instance
when she tempted wounds was partly
inspired by the on-screen verbal
sparring between Hepburn and Spencer
Tracy in the many movies they made
together as we all know from his
boastful song no one does anything quite
like Gaston yet despite gaston's
insistence on his uniqueness the
filmmakers did actually draw inspiration
from a number of places when they
created his character first of all they
channeled the pompous Roman soldier
Mila's gloriosus from Stephen Sondheim's
musical a funny thing happened on the
way to the forum which was made into a
film in 1966 and was a particular
favorite abusing the beat producer Don
Hahn and lyricist Howard Ashman and when
she was writing the big headed Gaston
screenwriter Linda Woolverton also had
in mind some of her ex-boyfriends looks
wise the animators modeled Gaston after
good-looking soap opera stars and added
a dash of Superman as the idea was to
make him incredibly handsome and
basically the polar opposite of the
beast in both
finality and appearance speaking of the
Beast animator Glen Keane who designed
that character was banned from meeting
actor Robby Benson who voiced the beast
until after the movie was finished which
was very unusual because on other
animated movies Keane normally spent
time with the actors during their
recording sessions however Jeffrey
Katzenberg who is Disney studio chief at
the time specifically didn't want Keane
to be influenced by Benson's looks
personality or mannerisms and how he
animated the beast as for the design of
the Beast that was based on a variety of
animals that Keane observed and sketched
at London Zoo in Regent's Park including
wolf gorillas and mandrels whose eyes I
felt was very human and conveyed real
intelligence Keane also brought a
buffalo head from a taxidermist and in
the end the features of the beast
combined a lion's mane a Buffalo's head
a gorilla sprout human eyes a cow's ears
a bird body and a wolf's tail in length
when making animated movies more often
than not actors record their roles
separately but the Beauty and the Beast
page ohhara persuaded Disney's
powers-that-be to let her and Robby
Benson record Belle and beasts lines
together which they found really helped
them get the dynamic right between their
characters as it developed over the
course of the story by the way Benson
prefers that his beauty in the beasts
recording sessions by doing the kind of
vocal warm-ups he used to get ready when
he performed in Broadway shows it's
almost hard to imagine now that we know
the movie so well but several of the
film's characters started out with
different names in earlier versions of
the story mrs. Potts was actually called
mrs. camomile the filmmakers originally
named her chamomile after the soothing
herbal tea but decided to change it when
it occurred to them it may be difficult
to pronounce especially for young
children as the Jerry Orbach character
Lumiere he was initially going to be
named Shandell short for the word
chandelier but again the filmmakers
thought the name would be too tough to
say so instead they went with the name
we know today which was inspired by
early cinema pioneers the Lumiere
brothers
mrs. Potts may sound wonderfully
soothing singing about the tale as old
as time in the movies title track
however what happened to actress Angela
Lansbury right before she recorded a
song with a pink burst
Lansbury was on her way to record the
tune with the New York Philharmonic when
the plane she was on was forced to make
an emergency landing in Las Vegas due to
a bomb scare
although producer Don Hahn suggested she
rest
overnight in Las Vegas undeterred
Lansbury caught another flight and
continued on her journey to New York
that same day going straight into her
recording session with the Philharmonic
where she nailed the song in just one
cake which is exactly what we hear in
the film originally mrs. Potts unship
was only supposed to say a single
sentence in the whole movie and that
line was mum Arthur's a girl in the
castle the rest of the scenes where chip
appears in the film as it stands today
were actually meant to feature a music
box which instead of speaking made
little chiming noises
however the filmmakers decided they
wanted to add a child's perspective to
the movie in order to make it easier for
kids to relate to the story and because
they liked child actor Bradley Michael
Pierce's voices chips they kept
increasing his dialogue one of the most
enchanting parts of Beauty and the Beast
is it songs so it's incredible to think
that composer Alan Menken and lyricist
Howard Ashman ever doubted their
brilliance that even a second in fact
they were so uncertain what the
filmmakers would like the opening song
they'd written for valve that they flew
from upstate New York where they'd
written the soundtrack all the way to
Los Angeles to play it in person for the
filmmaking team basically Menken and
Ashman were worried the filmmakers would
think they've gone mad because they
covered so many details in the space of
just a few minutes in that first song so
for example we meet Belle Gaston and
Lefou and we find out what kind of
people they are and we learn all about
Belle's town and its inhabitants and how
they're so different from her but Menken
and Ashman shouldn't have worried as the
Beauty and the Beast crew loved the song
and the entertaining way it presented so
much information and set up many of the
film's main characters and in fact the
song Belle actually ended up being one
of a small number of tracks that didn't
get changed or rearranged over the
course of the movies development so how
big a fan are you of Beauty and the
Beast and how many facts did you know
and which is your favorite character and
song in the movies let me know in the
comments below I've got lots more Beauty
in the Beast videos on the way including
some very cool secrets about the making
of the new movie so do subscribe and
turn on your notifications for flicks in
the city to make sure you don't miss any
of my new videos and if you enjoyed this
I really appreciate you giving it a
thumbs up and sharing it and why not tap
or click here to check out some more
videos you might like on my channel
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
us